.
>> AFTER THE YEAR WE HAD -- OH!
IF YOU ARE PLANNING FAMILY
ACTIVITIES THIS SUMMER, WE HAVE
GOT SOME EXPERT ADVICE FOR YOU.
OUR DR. TARA NARULA AND
BEST-SELLING AUTHOR GRETCHEN
RUBIN JOINS US, GRETCHEN WROTE
"THE HAPPINESS PROJECT" AN
EXCELLENT BOOK.
GOOD MORNING, GUYS.
>> GOOD MORNING.
>> I'M SO HAPPY TO SPEAK TO BOTH
OF YOU, DR. NARULA, WHAT IS A
GOOD WAY, YOU AND I HAVE KIDS
AROUND SIMILAR AGES.
WHAT'S A GOOD WAY TO HAVE MENTAL
WELLNESS, AND YET BE MEDICALLY
SAFE AS WE OPEN UP TRAVEL?
>> RIGHT.
SO, MY HUSBAND AND I ARE BOTH
VACCINATED.
OUR KIDS ARE NOT BECAUSE THEY'RE
UNDER THE AGE OF 12, SO I WANT
TO FOCUS ON THAT FIRST WHICH IS
THAT THIS IS THE BRIGHT SPOT OF
THIS SUMMER.
WITH PARENTS BEING VACCINATED,
WE KNOW THAT OUR KIDS ARE WAY
MORE PROTECTED THAN THEY WERE
LAST SUMMER BECAUSE MOST OF THE
TRANSMISSION TO KIDS HAVE COME
FROM HOUSEHOLD CONTACT.
SOC
SO THE RISK FOR OUR KIDS IS MUCH
LOWER.
IT'S A FAMILY-BY-FAMILY,
CASE-BY-CASE DECISION.
THAT'S BASED ON YOUR LEVEL OF
RISK TOLERANCE OR VERSION.
WHAT ARE THE PARTICULAR HEALTH
ISSUES OF YOUR CHILDREN?
ARE THEY CHILDREN AT HIGHER RISK
FOR COMPLICATIONS OF COVID?
AND WHAT ARE THE GOALS OF THE
FAMILY.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT WHAT YOU CAN DO
THIS SUMMER THERE ARE A LOT OF
OPTIONS, OUTDOOR.
OUTDOOR.
OUTDOOR ACTIVITIES, HIKING,
CAMPING, OUTDOOR SPORTS FOR KIDS
WHERE THEY DON'T HAVE CLOSE
CONTACT.
OUTDOOR PLAY MATES, OUTDOOR
DINING.
THEN YOU WANT TO THINK TRAVEL,
ROAD TRIPS, THINK WALLY WORLD.
ROAD TRAVEL IS GOING TO BE THE
SAFEST.
FINALLY CAMP IS A GREAT OPTION.
CAMP WAS AN OPTION LAST SUMMER.
AND IT WORKED VERY WELL WITH THE
MAJORITY OF CAMPS.
FIND OUT WHAT PROTOCOLS THEY'RE
TAKING.
LOTS OF CHOICES FOR KIDS.
>> AND, GRETCHEN, I CAN'T THINK
OF ANYBODY BETTER THAN YOU TO
TALK ABOUT HOW WE KEEP HAPPINESS
ALIVE AFTER THE FEAR THAT WE'VE
ALL CARRIED WITH US FOR WELL
OVER A YEAR NOW.
>> RIGHT.
AS WE'RE NAVIGATING BEING IN
DIFFERENT CIRCUMSTANCES WITH
PEOPLE WHO MIGHT HAVE DIFFERENT
PRACTICES, DIFFERENT SYSTEMS, OR
THEY NEED TO -- WE NEED TO THINK
ABOUT JUST HAVING GOOD MANNERS.
AND TRYING TO MAKE PEOPLE FEEL
AS COMFORTABLE AND AS CONFIDENT
AS THEY CAN WITH WHATEVER THE
CONDITIONS ARE.
>> SO, TARA, HOW DO WE LET KIDS
HAVE A KIDS WILL BE KIDS SUMMER
BUT TAKE CARE OF THEIR MENTAL
HEALTH.
I REALLY BELIEVE MOST OF US
DON'T KNOW WHAT WE'VE BEEN
THROUGH UNTIL WE'RE OUT OF IT.
I DON'T ANY OF US KNOW HOW WE'RE
AFFECTED UNTIL THAT TIME.
>> I THINK YOU'RE RIGHT, GAYLE.
FOR SO MANY OF US WHO HAVE HAD
KIDS WE'VE HEARD THEM, TALK
ABOUT BEING ANXIOUS, DEPRESSED.
LONELY, ISOLATED, STRESSED.
IF EVER THERE WAS A PRESCRIPTION
PAD FOR A DOCTOR THIS SUMMER FOR
KIDS IS PLAY AND FUN.
THOSE NEED TO BE THE TWO WORDS
FOR THIS YEAR'S SUMMER.
YOU KNOW, KIDS, WE SHOULD BE
TALKING TO THEM AND ASKING THEM
HOW DO THEY WANT THEIR SUMMER TO
BE.
WHAT IS IMPORTANT TO THEM.
LISTENING TO THEM AND
ACKNOWLEDGING HOW THEY FEEL.
AS YOU SAID, GAYLE, SO MANY OF
US HAVE BEEN REALLY FOCUSED ON
OUR OWN STRESSES AND STRUGGLES
AS PARENTS AND WE HAVEN'T
ACTUALLY TAKEN THE TIME TO ASK
OUR KIDS WHAT IS GOING ON IN
YOUR MIND.
ARE YOU NERVOUS ABOUT
RE-ENGAGING WITH KIDS IN CAMP OR
EVEN NEXT YEAR IN SCHOOL.
I THINK, LISTEN, ACTIVITIES,
BEING OUTDOORS, BEING CREATIVE
AND REALLY ALLOWING KIDS TO
SOCIALIZE.
THESE ARE THE THINGS WE SHOULD
FOCUS ON.
>> WHAT A GREAT IDEA.
ASK THE KIDS WHAT DO THEY WANT.
IT MIGHT BE MARITAL COUNSELING,
ASK YOUR HUSBAND WHAT HE'S
THINKING.
OH, OKAY.
YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT ABOUT
THAT.
ASK THEM, WHAT DO THEY WANT.
>> GRETCHEN, YOU SAID FAMILIES
SHOULD DESIGN THEIR SUMMER.
WHAT DO YOU MEAN BY THAT?
>> ABSOLUTELY DESIGN YOUR
SUMMER.
REALLY THINK ABOUT WHAT IS THE
ESSENCE OF SUMMER FOR YOU.
WHAT IS IT THAT YOU REALLY WANT
YOUR SUMMER TO HOLD AND FIGURE
OUT HOW TO BUILD THAT IN.
WE'VE ALL THAT EXPERIENCE OF
ORGANIZING THAT MAGICAL PICNIC,
GOING TO THAT THEME PARK, AND
SOMEHOW, THE TIME JUST GETS AWAY
FROM US.
WE WANT TO DESIGN OUR SUMMER SO
WE MAKE SURE WE FIGURE OUT WHAT
WE WANT.
THIS YEAR, WE MAY HAVE TO BE
MORE CREATIE AND ADAPTABLE.
WE MAY NOT BE ABLE TO DO THE
THINGS THAT WE WOULD TYPICALLY
DO.
YOU KNOW, THE DAYS ARE LONG, BUT
THE SUMMER IS SHORT.
AND WE REALLY WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE FILL THE TIME WITH THE
THINGS THAT ARE GOING TO GIVE US
THE ESSENCE OF SUMMER.
AND REALLY GIVE US THAT
EXPERIENCE OF THE SEASON, THAT
WE ALL REALLY WANT.
>> DR. NARULA, HOW DO WE WORD
THINGS TO CHILDREN?
A FEW KEY PHRASES, WHEN SOCIETY,
AND THE GLOBE IS GIVING US MIXED
MESSAGES ON MASK WEARING, WHAT'S
SAFE, WHAT IS NOT.
WHAT ARE KEY PHRASES TO KEEP
OPTIMISM ALIVE BUT CAUTION AND
RESPECT AT THE SAME TIME.
>> WELL, DREW, YOU'RE EXACTLY
RIGHT.
THIS YEAR HAS BEEN SO FULL OF
CHALLENGES.
AND I THINK WHAT WE WANT TO
TEACH OUR KIDS IS THAT IT'S OKAY
TO HAVE CHALLENGE.
YOU CAN RISE FROM THE CHALLENGE.
AND THERE ARE THREE WORDS I
LOVE, I ACTUALLY STOLE TWO OF
THEM FROM MY DAUGHTER'S SCHOOL,
GLOWS AND GROWS AND GRATITUDE,
THE THREE "G"s.
WHEN WE SIT AROUND, WE ASK THE
KIDS, WHAT ARE YOUR GLOWS FROM
TODAY?
WHERE DID YOU SHINE?
WE WANT THEM TO HAVE THAT
POSITIVE FEEDBACK.
AND WHERE CAN YOU GROW?
MAYBE YOU FAILED AT SOMETHING,
THAT'S OKAY.
AND FINALLY, HOW CAN YOU FIND
GRATITUDE.
THERE'S ALWAYS SOMETHING IN
EVERY DAY THAT YOU CAN BE
GRATEFUL FOR.
THE LAUGHING IS THE SILVER
LINING.
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT'S HUGE IN
OUR HOUSEHOLD.
WE'RE ALWAYS TRYING TO TEACH OUR
KIDS TO FIND THE BRIGHT SPOTS.
LOOK AT THE WORLD, SEE AS YOU
SAID, OPTIMISM, AND HOPE AND
BEAUTY.
FOR US, OUR SILVER LINING OUR
TWO GIRLS GOT CLOSER IN A YEAR
WHERE THEY NEVER WOULD HAVE HAD
THIS TIME TOGETHER.
FOR MY 8-YEAR-OLD, I ASKED HER
WHAT WAS YOUR SILVER LINING, SHE
SAID, WELL I GOT TO SLEEP LONGER
THAN I WOULD HAVE IF I ACTUALLY
WENT TO SCHOOL.
>> GLOWS AND GROWS AND
GRATITUDE.